i'm excited to do this we have our man
homeless pimp uh
which which by the way we've said some
of the hardest we've ever laughed
is you know we like a guy who's got a
funny name a wild name
you know i don't know him personally but
anytime we hear machine gun kelly
it's just a very very it's a it's very
funny to think about we were in denver
yeah with uh pete davidson was
performing there
and it was one of those things where
pete davidson hangs out with machine gun
kelly a lot
and uh we're in the green room of denver
comedy works we're about to go and then
i said to salas do you want to go over
to denver comedy works
they were in the group you were you were
doing you and i you were headlining the
theater
i was opening for you at the theater and
then pete was headlining comedy works
denver he was just there with him ricky
he like did that thing pete could do
that it's great she shows up
shea and pete do that yeah i think
they're like i think i'm going to
perform this weekend at this place and
then it's like
it shall show that i was like i mean i
was very lucky to perform
at the paramount i think it was who i
think they share i think they run i
think it's all like the same owners of
bookers yeah you know that
yeah but i was happy but i do have to
sell for like six to eight months to get
that done
and it's one of those things where it's
like you know where where
where comics comics you know they're
there in denver
and we're like you know let's go hang
out and then you know ricky texts me
great ricky velez great comic uh awesome
good friend of mine
and he's um and he says he says yeah he
goes you know there's room in here it's
a little tight
he said because you know pete's here and
then also machine gun kelly and then you
have to ask yourself
i'm a fan of machine gun kelly's music
eyes salad you have to ask you so you
know i said to myself we're in the van
on the way there
and i said you know i got a
three-year-old daughter sal's 40.
are we gonna be in a are we at a point
our lives right now
where we want to be sharing a space
albeit we're fans
with the guy who goes by machine gun
kelly yeah has that ship
sailed and you know it's nothing against
him no
he might be terrific it's just that
something comes with a name
right i just said to you i feel like
jabba the hutt yeah
so you when i say that you get a sense
of what i mean right when someone has an
automatic weapon in their name
in their name yeah i don't know what
we're stepping into you know one day you
want to have a family and all that and i
have my daughter and i just feel like
you know what you know the machine gun
kelly it's like something you do when
you're in your 20s you know you want to
have a party a little bit
not those guys are still in their 20s i
think well pete is right pizza is 20
young kids ricky might be 30ish
but they're still very distant you know
what uh they still have
uh worried like they have never thought
minute on the lips lifetime on the hips
they have never thought about that
they're very thin and i don't think they
work at it yeah which by the way that
sets us apart
ricky velez if you don't know ricky
velez if you should know his comedy but
just in case you don't he was in pete's
movie king of uh staten island
um which just came out great movie go
check it out but ricky's what i loved it
what was funny to me about that movie
is when ricky got shot in the movie
oh you haven't seen it no i want to i
just told you ricky got shot
sorry he gets shot ricky gets shot that
must have been so fun to shoot i gotta
ask him about it ricky gets shot and
then goes to jail
but then you never find out what
happened to him you never find out
anything get out
get out the movie just ends and you're
like all right well i guess i'm just
gonna have to constantly now think about
is ricky dead or alive and how long was
his prison term wow
yeah but so but but more so we were
laughing because we always we were
pontificating what do you call machine
gun kelly
when you when you know him like he said
you call him machine do you call machine
or like what about when he's going to
the doctor's office is it is it
mr kelly i wonder why mr machine do you
know his real name
he's not kelly that's a whole moniker is
machine gun kelly's
yeah mike's going to look oh they
probably call him his real name which i
don't know what it is
but they wouldn't tell us that bill
smith is there because we don't know who
that is
right so ricky has to tell you machine
gun kelly and then we say
like i don't know if i would go high
machine gun kelly i don't know what i
would say
yeah hey yeah mr mr machine or yeah
mister guns
the gun oh oh god okay so his name is
richard
baker oh cool i remember that coulson
yeah coulson yeah oh i thought his first
name was colson richard coulson baker so
rick
rich they call home rich i don't know
what you call anyone know what you're
gonna be calling
like but what do you call any of these
people like i don't know you know like
what do you call freaking um
anybody weekend the weekend what do you
call the weekend hi the weekend high the
weekend
and you don't want to disrespect you
don't want to you don't want to shorten
it you don't say well it's a weekend
yeah you don't know me like that yeah
like what are you saying hey weekend
please my father was weekend call me the
no yeah like yeah the weekend yeah what
do you call it yeah i don't know they
probably call him his real name that's
probably what it is does anybody know
did we make a mistake not making
like fake like names for ourselves for
the public it's one of those things
i think we did in a sense but it's one
of those things what would be your name
where it's like i don't know what my
name would be
well what are you talking about you name
you have a hundred nicknames i know
i know i have a hundred it's chrissy
then whatever you feel
whatever yeah christy conquistador yeah
chrissy [ __ ] hips like whatever
whatever
crystal clear chrissy crystal clear
chrissy christie conspiracies yeah
um chrissy colonoscopies i just yeah i
can just
so i guess i do have the names but i
feel as if like
being a white guy in entertainment we're
not we don't we go by
usually the first and last name and a
black comedian usually will go by a
nickname or just their first name
you